Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. I can't spell it right. So you just give a fake name, your cafe name, Julia. But the more you use it, the more it feels like you're in witness protection. Wait a minute. What kind of espresso drinks does Julia like anyway? Is it too late to change your latte order? But with an espresso machine by KitchenAid, you wouldn't be thinking any of this because you could have just made your espresso at home.
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、享受无广告收听体验、抢先观看系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我总是拼不对。所以你随便报个假名，比如咖啡馆的名字，朱莉娅。但你用得越多，就越觉得像是在接受证人保护。等等。朱莉娅到底喜欢喝什么样的浓缩咖啡？现在改点拿铁还来得及吗？但如果有一台 KitchenAid 浓缩咖啡机，你就不会有这些烦恼了，因为你完全可以在家自制浓缩咖啡。
Shop now at KitchenAid.ca The garden was called the Garden of Delights and in the middle of the garden was a palace called the Palace of Marvels belonging to the Caliph Harun al-Rashid. Whenever the Caliph felt his chest constricted, he would come to this garden and this palace to breathe freely, to amuse himself and forget his cares. The entire palace was formed of one immense chamber,
立即前往 KitchenAid.ca 选购。这座花园被称为“极乐园”，花园中央有一座名为“奇迹宫”的宫殿，属于哈里发哈伦·拉希德。每当哈里发感到胸闷时，他就会来到这座花园和宫殿，呼吸新鲜空气，消遣娱乐，忘却烦恼。整座宫殿由一个巨大的厅堂组成，
lighted by 80 windows. This chamber was opened only when the caliph came. Then all the lamps and the great chandelier would be lighted, and all the windows flung open, and the caliph would sit on his great divan, covered in silk, velvet, and cloth of gold, and cause his singers to sing and musicians to delight him with their music. So that, Tom, was the Arabian Nights. And that is a description of the Caliph Harun al-Rashid, the person who is the embodiment of the golden age of Baghdad, the subject of the new Assassin's Creed video game, and a subject that you've long wanted to do on The Rest is History, Tom. We're two episodes in, and this is the high point of medieval Islamic civilization, isn't it? It is, but I think it's also seen, as that passage that you read suggests, it's seen almost as a city of myth. And that, I think, is largely because of the Arabian Nights that we'll talk about in our final episode. But the sense of Baghdad as a place of romance, of poetry, of myth, is a crucial part of the resonance that it has, I think.
由 80 扇窗户采光。这个厅堂只有哈里发驾临时才会开启。届时，所有的灯盏和巨大的吊灯都会点亮，所有的窗户都会敞开，哈里发会坐在他那铺着丝绸、天鹅绒和金布的巨大长榻上，让歌手们歌唱，让乐师们用音乐取悦他。所以，汤姆，这就是《一千零一夜》。而这正是对哈里发哈伦·拉希德的描述，他是巴格达黄金时代的化身，是新游戏《刺客信条》的主题，也是你一直想在《历史的余味》中探讨的主题，汤姆。我们已经播了两集了，这是伊斯兰中世纪文明的巅峰，对吧？确实，但我认为正如你读的那段文字所暗示的那样，它几乎被视为一座神话之城。我认为这很大程度上是因为我们将在最后一集讨论的《一千零一夜》。但我认为，巴格达作为浪漫、诗意和神话之地的感觉，是它所具有的共鸣中至关重要的一部分。
Because it is one of those great imperial cities like Rome, or indeed the London of Sherlock Holmes, that lives in the imagination as well as in the history books. Do you think, I mean, were you an Arabian Nights fan? Absolutely. But I think the interesting thing about it is that the Arabian Nights, whether it has the currency now that it would have done 50 or 100 years ago, I think in Western households, it's dubious. I mean, it was very much the sort of stuff of the middle or upper class nursery, wasn't it?
因为它就像罗马，或者夏洛克·福尔摩斯的伦敦一样，是那些伟大的帝国城市之一，既存在于想象中，也存在于历史书中。你觉得，我是说，你是《一千零一夜》的粉丝吗？当然。但我认为有趣的是，《一千零一夜》在西方家庭中是否还像 50 或 100 年前那样流行，这一点值得怀疑。我的意思是，它在很大程度上是中产阶级或上层阶级托儿所里的读物，不是吗？
They loved it. Yes. So if you'd asked me actually, Tom, where are the Arabian Nights set? If you'd asked me before this podcast, I would probably have struggled to tell you. I would have said Baghdad, Cairo. And you'd have been right because a lot of them are set in Cairo, but the foundational ones are set in Baghdad. And Harun al-Rashid is the embodiment of it because he is the caliph who lives in his palace, often goes out into the streets. That is because, as you said, he is identified as this peak moment in the great civilization of Islam. That, of course, opens up the question of, well, is it accurate? As so often, again and again over the rest of history, we've looked at the way that the past is mythologized
他们很喜欢。是的。所以汤姆，如果你之前问我，《一千零一夜》的故事背景在哪里？在录这期播客之前，我可能很难回答你。我会说巴格达、开罗。你说得对，因为其中很多故事发生在开罗，但奠基性的故事发生在巴格达。而哈伦·拉希德就是它的化身，因为他是那位住在宫殿里，却经常微服私访的哈里发。那是因为，正如你所说，他被视为伊斯兰伟大文明的巅峰时刻。这当然引出了一个问题：它准确吗？正如我们在《历史的余味》中一次又一次看到的那样，我们审视了过去被神话的方式，
and then asked, well, what is the reality behind it? I think there's a particular challenge with trying to work out whether the Baghdad of Harun al-Rashid really was the shimmering dimension of wonder that it is in the Arabian Nights, because it's completely vanished, partly because the Mongols obliterated it when they conquered it in the 13th century. But also, as with Babylon, because it is made of mud brick, not of stone. And so it's all kind of melted away into sludge. So the question of how golden was the golden age, how great a caliph was Harun al-Rashid? I think is a very interesting question and today's theme, Dominic. Great.
然后问，其背后的现实是什么？我认为，试图弄清楚哈伦·拉希德的巴格达是否真的是《一千零一夜》中那个闪烁着奇迹光芒的维度，是一个特殊的挑战，因为它已经完全消失了，部分原因是蒙古人在 13 世纪征服它时将其夷为平地。但也像巴比伦一样，因为它是由泥砖而非石头建造的。所以它最终都融化成了淤泥。因此，黄金时代到底有多“金”，哈伦·拉希德是一位多么伟大的哈里发？我认为这是一个非常有趣的问题，也是今天的主题，多米尼克。太棒了。
So, Tom, for those people who didn't listen last week, give us a bit of context. Where and when? We're in the Middle East, obviously. We're in modern-day Iraq. You talked last time about the foundation of Baghdad. But we're now well into the Abbasid caliphate. So these guys who had toppled the previous rulers, the Umayyads. So just sort of sketch that out a bit for us. So we're in the city of Baghdad, founded by al-Mansur, which we talked about in the
那么汤姆，对于那些没听上周节目的听众，给我们一点背景介绍。时间和地点？显然是在中东。我们在现代的伊拉克。你上次谈到了巴格达的建立。但我们现在已经深入阿拔斯王朝了。就是那些推翻了前任统治者倭马亚王朝的人。所以给我们简单勾勒一下。我们是在巴格达城，由曼苏尔建立，我们在
previous episode, the first great Abbasid caliph. Harun al-Rashid, which is the Arabic form of Aaron, the brother of Moses, and al-Rashid means the rightly guided. He is al-Mansur's grandson, and he rules between 786 and 809, according to the Christian calendar. And he's the grandson of al-Mansur, as I said, which means that he is the son of the guy that we talked about in the previous episode, almansoor's heir, who finds all the bodies of the descendants of Ali in the storeroom with the tags in their ear, if you remember. So this is a guy called Al-Mahdi, and he is much more easygoing than his rather austere and terrifying father. He's a great one for the wine and the sherbet and the dancing girls.
上一集讨论过，他是第一位伟大的阿拔斯哈里发。哈伦·拉希德，是阿拉伯语中“亚伦”（摩西的兄弟）的变体，而“拉希德”意为“正道者”。他是曼苏尔的孙子，根据基督教历法，他在 786 年至 809 年间统治。正如我所说，他是曼苏尔的孙子，这意味着他是我们在上一集讨论过的那位曼苏尔继承人的儿子，如果你还记得的话，他曾在储藏室里发现了所有阿里后裔的尸体，耳朵上还挂着标签。所以这个家伙叫马赫迪，他比他那位相当严厉且可怕的父亲要随和得多。他非常喜欢葡萄酒、果子露和舞女。
And also, Dominic, he's a particular fan of pigeon racing. So Gordon Crowe will be pleased to hear that. So he loves his pigeon racing. Pigeon racing, by this point, has become a massive obsession in Baghdad. Everyone's gambling on it. Haroon himself will love it. And Al-Jahiz, who is a great scholar, ends up being crushed to death beneath a huge pile of books. He writes that a pigeon could fetch as much as a farm. He's a great scholar, ends up being crushed to death beneath a huge pile of books.
而且，多米尼克，他还是赛鸽的狂热爱好者。所以戈登·克罗听到这个会很高兴的。他热爱赛鸽。到那时，赛鸽在巴格达已经成为一种巨大的痴迷。每个人都在赌博。哈伦本人也很喜欢。而伟大的学者贾希兹最终被压死在一堆巨大的书下。他写道，一只鸽子可以换一个农场。他是一位伟大的学者，最终被压死在一堆巨大的书下。
He writes that a pigeon could fetch as much as a farm. So this is the kind of the world that al-Mahdi is ruling over. And Harun is his son. But the story of Harun's reign is marked by all kinds of shenanigans that are very, very caliph. They're very caliph. Yeah. They're the kind of stuff that people will probably remember from the previous two episodes, that there are certain themes over the course of caliphal history that become quite familiar. So one of them is disputed succession. So Harun is the younger son of al-Mahdi. And his elder brother al-Hadi, he succeeds al-Mahdi, he's very young, he's kind of 25. But Harun is al-Mahdi's favorite son. And so al-Mahdi has
他写道，一只鸽子可以换一个农场。这就是马赫迪统治下的世界。哈伦是他的儿子。但哈伦统治时期的故事充满了各种非常“哈里发式”的诡计。非常哈里发。是的。这些就是人们可能从前两集中记得的内容，即在哈里发历史的过程中，某些主题变得非常熟悉。其中之一就是继承权之争。哈伦是马赫迪的次子。他的长兄哈迪继承了马赫迪，他很年轻，大概 25 岁。但哈伦是马赫迪最宠爱的儿子。所以马赫迪已经
appointed him the crown prince, meaning that he will definitely succeed al-Hadi when al-Hadi dies. But al-Hadi doesn't like this at all. He's not keen on this arrangement at all. Because he has a son. He has an infant son. Obviously, he wants to get rid of his brother. So this is kind of alarming for Harun, who is clearly not very popular with his elder brother. And what makes it more dangerous for him is al-Hadi is a very menacing figure. So al-Masudi, who's a great historian writing in the 10th century, says of al-Hadi that, who's a great historian writing in the 10th century, says of al-Hadi that he was hard, he was coarse in his habits, he was difficult to approach.
任命他为王储，这意味着当哈迪去世时，他肯定会继位。但哈迪一点也不喜欢这样。他一点也不喜欢这个安排。因为他有一个儿子。他有一个年幼的儿子。显然，他想除掉他的弟弟。所以这对哈伦来说有点令人担忧，他显然在长兄那里不太受欢迎。更危险的是，哈迪是一个非常有威胁性的人物。所以 10 世纪的伟大历史学家马苏迪在谈到哈迪时说，他性格强硬，习惯粗鲁，难以接近。
He was the first caliph to be preceded by bodyguards carrying naked swords, clubs, and bows ready strung. And part of this, Tom, is because in the caliphal system, it's not primogeniture. It could be anybody who succeeds. There's an inbuilt, inherent struggle for power. So there's not an assembly that chooses. It's just whoever garrots his siblings first. Yeah, pretty much. Because the figure of the caliph and his relationship to the mass of the Muslim people is something also that is constantly open for negotiation. And so therefore, the corollary of that is that the qualifications to be caliph are kind of a movable feast. But ultimately, of course, it depends on raw power. But if you are in position of the caliphal throne, then your power to get rid of unwanted younger brothers is pretty extensive.
他是第一位由佩戴裸剑、棍棒和拉满弓的保镖随行的哈里发。汤姆，部分原因是哈里发制度中没有长子继承制。任何人都可以继位。这其中有一种内在的、固有的权力斗争。所以没有一个议会来选择。谁先勒死兄弟，谁就是哈里发。是的，差不多。因为哈里发及其与广大穆斯林民众的关系也是不断需要协商的。因此，其推论就是，成为哈里发的资格是一种变数。但归根结底，这取决于原始权力。但如果你坐上了哈里发的宝座，那么你除掉不受欢迎的弟弟的权力就相当大了。
So this is alarming for Harun. And there are various accounts of how much danger he's actually in during al-Hadi's reign. There are reports that he ends up in prison. We don't really know. They're very mythologized, these stories. But what is very clear, and again, an absolute theme of early Caliphal history, is that the role played by very powerful women in the background is absolutely key. So al-Hadi and Harun share the same mother. And this mother is a very, very significant player. So she is called al-Khazaran. She's a former slave from Yemen. She had been bought by al-Mansur, so the founder of Baghdad, in Mecca.
这对哈伦来说很令人担忧。关于他在哈迪统治期间到底处于多大的危险之中，有各种各样的说法。有报道称他最终被关进了监狱。我们并不真正知道。这些故事被高度神话化了。但非常清楚的是，这又是早期哈里发历史的一个绝对主题，即背景中非常有权势的女性所扮演的角色是绝对关键的。哈迪和哈伦是同母异父（注：此处原文有误，应为同母兄弟）。这位母亲是一位非常、非常重要的人物。她叫海祖兰。她曾是来自也门的奴隶。她是在麦加被曼苏尔（巴格达的建立者）买下的。
And he had then given her as a kind of present to al-Maudi, his son. And she was incredibly beautiful, slender and graceful as a reed, she was described as. And she is very smart, very witty, very, very politically savvy. She sounds great, Tom. She really is great, I think. And al-Maudi becomes besotted by her, makes her his legal wife. And that means that when he dies and al-Hadi succeeds, she's the queen mother. She is a figure of considerable power. Al-Hadi, of course, becomes very resentful of this, a bit like Nero becoming very resentful of his mother Agrippina. She's pretty autonomous.
然后他把她作为礼物送给了他的儿子马赫迪。她非常漂亮，被形容为像芦苇一样苗条优雅。她非常聪明、机智，而且非常有政治头脑。她听起来很棒，汤姆。我认为她真的很棒。马赫迪对她神魂颠倒，让她成为了他的合法妻子。这意味着当他去世、哈迪继位时，她就是皇太后。她是一个拥有相当大权力的人物。哈迪当然对此感到非常怨恨，有点像尼禄对他的母亲阿格里皮娜感到非常怨恨。她相当自主。
She's inherited lots of wealth. She has a great palace. She has lots of petitioners who are constantly asking her for favors. And she is then coming to Al-Hadi and demanding that he do what she wants him to. And he becomes very, very resentful of this. And so, again, a bit like Nero, he ends up trying to kill her. At least, that's the story. The story goes that he sends her a dish of rice, saying that he had found this dish of rice so tasty that he wants her to have a bit of it. And Kaisaran, by this point, is getting a bit nervous. So she feeds a little bit of it to her dog that probably keels over, frothing at the mouth and dies. And so she then sends back saying, yes, it was delicious. I loved it. So this is tense. And
她继承了大量的财富。她有一座宏伟的宫殿。她有很多请愿者不断向她寻求恩惠。然后她来到哈迪面前，要求他做她想做的事。他对此变得非常、非常怨恨。所以，又有点像尼禄，他最终试图杀死她。至少，故事是这么说的。故事说他送给她一盘米饭，说他发现这盘米饭太好吃了，想让她也尝尝。海祖兰此时已经有点紧张了。所以她喂了一点给她的狗，狗可能当场口吐白沫倒地而死。于是她回信说，是的，太美味了。我很喜欢。所以气氛很紧张。而且
it's, I guess, not surprising that soon after this, after Al-Hadi has tried to poison his mother, that Al-Hadi himself goes down with terrible stomach pains and dies soon afterwards. The official statement is that he's died of a stomach ulcer. But of course, there are lots of people who say, oh, well, he was poisoned by his mother. And there are other excellent stories that say that he's choking, breathing his last, and Kaisaran, his mother, absolutely finishes him off by getting a very large buttocked slave girl to sit on his face and smother him to death. Brilliant, Tom. Brilliant brilliant so that's exactly the kind of conduct that i expected would be taking place in baghdad in the um the eighth and ninth centuries or whatever yes but
我想，在这之后不久，在哈迪试图毒死他的母亲之后，哈迪本人就患上了严重的胃痛，不久后就去世了，这并不令人惊讶。官方声明是他死于胃溃疡。但当然，有很多人说，哦，他是被他母亲毒死的。还有其他精彩的故事说，当他窒息、呼吸最后一口气时，他的母亲海祖兰通过让一个臀部非常大的女奴坐在他脸上将他闷死，彻底终结了他。太精彩了，汤姆。太精彩了，这正是我想象中八九世纪巴格达会发生的那种行为。是的，但是
listen so this is also very roman yes it is right it's very similar to the kind of julio claudian behavior so with the romans the period you've written about the sources are all very dodgy and propagandistic is that also the case with all this, with this whole period? I think so. They're written about a century later. So I'm absolutely not going to say it didn't happen. We all hope it did, but treat it with a pinch of salt. Treat it with a pinch of salt. But of course, there's no smoke without fire. These stories in themselves tell you about the dynamics that are operative in the court. And I think absolutely one of these kind of themes that these stories does reflect is the fact that women in this period have a great deal of power, probably much more power than they will in due course. and what kaiseran was to al-mahdi haroon's cousin a woman called zabida is to haroon his favorite wife so he has three other wives yeah uh he also has 200 women in his harem who give him over 20 children so he's he's very active yes um and one of them actually dominic is a greek so she's called
听着，这也非常罗马。是的，没错，这和朱里奥-克劳狄王朝的行为非常相似。对于罗马人，你写过的那个时期，资料来源都非常不可靠且具有宣传色彩。这个时期也是这样吗？我想是的。它们是在一个世纪后写的。所以我绝对不会说它没有发生。我们都希望它发生了，但要持保留态度。持保留态度。但当然，无风不起浪。这些故事本身就告诉了你宫廷中运作的动态。我认为这些故事反映的主题之一绝对是，这一时期的女性拥有巨大的权力，可能比她们后来拥有的权力要大得多。而海祖兰对马赫迪而言，哈伦的表亲，一个叫祖拜达的女人，对哈伦来说就是他最宠爱的妻子。所以他还有三个妻子，是的，他还有 200 个后宫女性，为他生了 20 多个孩子，所以他非常活跃。是的，其中一个其实是希腊人，她叫
helena ah the mother of constantine yes um she becomes mistress of the harem and she's uh ends up so so celebrated across baghdad for her beauty that supposedly she gives her name to a quarter of baghdad helana oh i mean that's whether that's really where the name of that quarter comes from again i mean who knows yeah but anyway the tradition is which is preserved in the arabian nights where zubaydah is always going out with Harun on expeditions across Baghdad. She's famously beautiful, of course. She has exquisite taste. She's the arch-influencer in Baghdad, incredibly fond of luxury. Rather brilliantly, she owns a monkey that has 30 attendants. And whenever people come in to see her,
海伦娜。啊，君士坦丁的母亲。是的，她成为了后宫的女主人，她最终在整个巴格达因美貌而闻名，据说她以自己的名字命名了巴格达的一个区。海伦娜。哦，我的意思是，那个区的名字是否真的来源于此，谁知道呢。但无论如何，传统是这样的，这在《一千零一夜》中得到了保留，祖拜达总是和哈伦一起在巴格达各地探险。她当然非常出名，美貌绝伦。她品味极高。她是巴格达的顶级网红，极其喜欢奢侈品。相当精彩的是，她养了一只猴子，有 30 个侍从。每当人们进来见她时，
they have to kiss the hand of the monkey. So that sounds to me like the kind of detail probably cannot be true. No, Dominic, it's definitely true because in due course, we know for a fact that a general comes in, is told to kiss the hand of the monkey and is so furious that he draws his sword out and chops the monkey in two. Is that the kind of detail that's invented? I don't think so. Enough of your relentless skepticism. So the monkey has 30 slaves. I mean, I raise an eyebrow at that, shall we say, Tom? So weirdly, throughout Islamic history, the possession of monkeys is seen as a marker of something that's not quite right. An earlier caliph had had a monkey, and this was one of
他们都必须亲吻猴子的手。这听起来像是那种可能不是真的细节。不，多米尼克，这绝对是真的，因为后来我们确实知道，一位将军进来，被告知要亲吻猴子的手，他非常愤怒，以至于拔出剑将猴子劈成了两半。这是那种被编造出来的细节吗？我不这么认为。别再表现出你那无休止的怀疑了。所以猴子有 30 个奴隶。我的意思是，汤姆，我对此表示怀疑，可以这么说吧？奇怪的是，在整个伊斯兰历史上，拥有猴子被视为某种不太对劲的标志。早期的哈里发也养过猴子，这是针对他的
the black marks that was levelled against him to justify rebellion. So I think that it could be the sense of Zubaydah as having jeweled slippers, lots of extravagance, having a monkey is deliberately hyped because what's undoubtedly the case is that she is simultaneously very pious. So I think there's a kind of Jekyll and Hyde representation there in her character, because she is famous for her generosity to the poor in obedience to the mandates of Islam. And she also sponsors the building of hostels along the great road that leads from Baghdad to Mecca. And so this pilgrimage route comes to be known as the Dab Zubaydah, the Zubaydah road, the Zubaydah trail. And she gives Har the zebeda trail and she gives haruna son
黑点之一，被用来为叛乱辩护。所以我认为，祖拜达穿着镶满珠宝的拖鞋、极度奢侈、养着猴子的形象是被刻意炒作的，因为毫无疑问的是，她同时也非常虔诚。所以我认为她的性格中有一种“杰基尔与海德”式的表现，因为她以对穷人的慷慨而闻名，以服从伊斯兰教的命令。她还资助了从巴格达通往麦加的大道沿途旅馆的建设。因此，这条朝圣路线被称为“祖拜达之路”。她给了哈伦一个儿子
al-amin and so obviously she's very keen that al-amin yeah will become the heir so tom you know zebeda who she reminds me of great friend of the rest of history is the empress theodora because she conforms to the same stereotype of being on the one hand kind of luxurious and sensual and erotic and on the the other, kind to the poor. Yes, and pious and austere. It's a formula, isn't it? I think it is, yes. It's a formula, a literary formula for describing queens and empresses, I guess. I think it is.
阿明，所以很显然她非常渴望阿明会成为继承人。所以汤姆，你知道祖拜达让我想起了谁吗？《历史的余味》的好朋友，狄奥多拉皇后。因为她符合同样的刻板印象：一方面奢侈、感性、色情，另一方面又对穷人仁慈。是的，而且虔诚、朴素。这是一个公式，不是吗？我想是的。这是一个文学公式，用来描述女王和皇后，我想。我想是的。
And I think, yes, I think it channels ambivalences that pious Muslim men feel about a female patron of charity and good works. I'm sure that's right. The other thing, of course, that everyone knows about from the Arabian Nights is that caliphs have viziers. Of course, I'm sure that's right. The other thing, of course, that everyone knows about from the Arabian Nights is that Caliphs have viziers. Of course, I love a vizier. And Harun has tremendous viziers. So they all belong to a family called the Barmakids,
而且我认为，是的，我认为它传达了虔诚的穆斯林男性对女性慈善赞助人和善行者的矛盾心理。我相信那是对的。当然，每个人从《一千零一夜》中知道的另一件事是，哈里发有维齐尔（宰相）。当然，我相信那是对的。当然，每个人从《一千零一夜》中知道的另一件事是，哈里发有维齐尔。当然，我喜欢维齐尔。哈伦有非常了不起的维齐尔。他们都属于一个叫巴尔马基德的家族，
which I think is a great word. Yeah. Great name for, you know, a toy shop or something. Well, surely the Barmak Kids is like some peculiar... It's the Barmer Kids. Very good. Hey, hey, for the Barmer Kids. See, I was thinking, is that some kind of weird northern word for a bap or a roll?
我觉得这是一个很棒的词。是的。给玩具店之类的起个好名字。好吧，巴尔马基德（Barmakids）听起来就像某种奇怪的……是巴默小子（Barmer Kids）。非常好。嘿，嘿，为了巴默小子。看，我在想，那是不是某种奇怪的北方词汇，指面包或卷饼？
A Barmer Kid. I think that's what they call baguettes in Rotherham. I guess it could be. No, I think you get it on Nickelodeon. The zany antics of the Barmer Kids. In fact, they're from Balkh in what's now northern Afghanistan. Oh, yeah. You know, they're a long way from the heartlands of the Caliphate.
巴默小子。我想那是罗瑟勒姆人对法棍的称呼。我想可能是。不，我想你会在尼克国际儿童频道上看到它。巴默小子的滑稽动作。事实上，他们来自现在阿富汗北部的巴尔赫。哦，是的。你知道，他们离哈里发国的中心地带很远。
Yeah. They'd originally been Buddhists, and they had only converted from Buddhism relatively recently in generational terms. And they had the kind of the patriarch of the Barmakids, a guy called Khalid al-Barmaki, he had joined the Abbasid revolution because people will remember that from the previous episode, the Abbasid revolution was incubating up in Khorasan. And so he becomes vizier to al-Saffah, who was the first of the Abbasid caliphs. And then under al-Mansur, he'd become a governor out in Khorasan. So he was a very, very able man, a brilliant financial whiz, but also a great general, crushes revolts, impeccably loyal to the Abbasids. And he has
是的。他们最初是佛教徒，在代际层面上，他们皈依佛教的时间相对较晚。巴尔马基德家族的族长，一个叫哈立德·阿尔·巴尔马基的人，他加入了阿拔斯革命，因为人们会记得上一集的内容，阿拔斯革命是在呼罗珊酝酿的。所以他成为了阿拔斯第一位哈里发萨法赫的维齐尔。然后在曼苏尔统治下，他成为了呼罗珊的总督。所以他是一个非常有能力的人，一个出色的金融天才，也是一位伟大的将军，镇压叛乱，对阿拔斯王朝忠心耿耿。他有
a son, Yahya, who is equally able and who is very intimately connected with Harun because Harun as a baby is nursed by Yahya's wife. And Yahya's wife has a son at almost exactly the same time as Harun, and so the two boys are brought up. And this boy Jaffar becomes Harun's closest friend. He's like a brother to him. And of course, he regards Yahya almost as a father. Particularly during the dark days of al-Hadi's rule, Yahya stays loyal to him, to Harun. And so when Harun becomes caliph, he feels an incredible sense of loyalty to Yahya. And Yahya is incredibly able and serves Harun very, very well. And fact, for centuries and centuries he will be remembered in the Muslim world as the absolute model of a great, wise, pious vizier. Just as Jafar, Yahya's son, the almost brother to Harun, will be remembered
一个儿子，叶海亚，同样能干，而且与哈伦关系非常亲密，因为哈伦婴儿时期是由叶海亚的妻子喂养的。叶海亚的妻子在几乎和哈伦同一时间生了一个儿子，所以这两个男孩是一起长大的。这个男孩贾法尔成为了哈伦最好的朋友。他就像他的兄弟一样。当然，他几乎把叶海亚视为父亲。特别是在哈迪统治的黑暗时期，叶海亚对他、对哈伦保持忠诚。所以当哈伦成为哈里发时，他对叶海亚有一种难以置信的忠诚感。叶海亚非常有能力，为哈伦服务得非常好。事实上，几个世纪以来，他将在穆斯林世界中被铭记为伟大、智慧、虔诚的维齐尔的绝对典范。正如贾法尔，叶海亚的儿子，哈伦的准兄弟，将被铭记
as the model of a dashing… He's kind of the embodiment of coolness, almost. Right. He's kind of almost a JFK figure. Crikey. He's charismatic. He's good looking. Is he like Charles Brandon, Duke of Suffolk? No, I don't think he is.
为潇洒的典范……他几乎是酷的化身。没错。他几乎是一个肯尼迪式的人物。天哪。他很有魅力。他长得很好看。他像萨福克公爵查尔斯·布兰登吗？不，我不这么认为。
Because Charles Brandon, Duke of Suffolk, Henry VIII's great friend, is, I mean, he's a lad. He's a rugby player. Jaffar is... He's a pigeon racer. ...is more delicate. So the description of him, to find words for his beauty, I mean, he's a lad. He's a rugby player. Jafar is- He's a pigeon racer. Is more delicate. So the description of him, to find words for his beauty, think of the purest gold coin of ancient Egypt, the pearl which glowing from the shell's depths breaks the diver's
因为亨利八世的好友萨福克公爵查尔斯·布兰登，我的意思是，他是个小伙子。他是个橄榄球运动员。贾法尔是……他是赛鸽手。……更精致。所以对他的描述，要找到形容他美貌的词，我的意思是，他是个小伙子。他是个橄榄球运动员。贾法尔是——他是赛鸽手。更精致。所以对他的描述，要找到形容他美貌的词，想想古埃及最纯净的金币，那颗从贝壳深处发光、让潜水员心碎的珍珠，
heart, or gold leaf floating from the craftsman's hand to gild the pages of a wondrous book. So that's not- No. That's not the Earl of Suffolk, is it? That's like Hephaestion, Alexander the Great's pal, maybe, or Patroclus or something. Yes, I think that's slightly closer because Jafar is the most fashionable man in Baghdad. He's very cultivated. He's very sophisticated.
或者从工匠手中飘落、为奇妙书籍页面镀金的金箔。所以那不是——不。那不是萨福克伯爵，对吧？那就像亚历山大大帝的好友赫费斯提翁，或者帕特罗克洛斯之类的。是的，我认为这稍微接近一点，因为贾法尔是巴格达最时髦的人。他很有修养。他非常老练。
He is a great sponsor of learning. He's very smart. He is the guy who opens the first paper factory in Baghdad using Chinese prisoners who've come from the distant eastern frontier. And in fact, a particular type of paper in the Arabic world is called Jafari, after Jafar. And basically, I think he's tremendous fun. And like Zubaydah, he is cast in the Arabian Nights and other stories as Harun's kind of companion in his adventures. He's basically seen as the ideal best friend, the model of a best friend. But then in 803, it all goes horribly wrong. Oh, no.
他是学习的伟大赞助人。他非常聪明。他是那个利用来自遥远东方边境的中国战俘在巴格达开设第一家造纸厂的人。事实上，阿拉伯世界的一种特殊纸张被称为“贾法里”，就是以贾法尔的名字命名的。基本上，我认为他非常有趣。而且像祖拜达一样，他在《一千零一夜》和其他故事中被塑造为哈伦冒险的伙伴。他基本上被视为理想的挚友，挚友的典范。但随后在 803 年，一切都变得极其糟糕。哦，不。
The Barma kids are wiped out on Harun's order. Jafar is actually executed. Yahya is thrown into prison and he dies there three years later. And the question of why this brilliant family who Harun has loved and who have served him so well, why they are brought down is a topic of much, much debate, understandably. There seems to be no definitive answer. So there are stories that Jafar had been having an illicit affair with Harun's sister and that this had offended him both on the personal and the political level. That Harun had worried that the Barmakids were becoming too powerful,
巴尔马基德家族在哈伦的命令下被消灭了。贾法尔实际上被处决了。叶海亚被投入监狱，三年后死在那里。关于这个哈伦深爱且服务得如此出色的家族为何被推翻，这是一个引起了广泛争论的话题，这是可以理解的。似乎没有明确的答案。所以有故事说贾法尔与哈伦的妹妹有私情，这在个人和政治层面上都冒犯了他。哈伦担心巴尔马基德家族变得太强大，
that they were a potential rival dynasty to his own. Or possibly another theory is that they weren't actually powerful enough, that they didn't have, because they were outsiders, because they had come from Khorasan, they didn't have the roots in Iraq that more powerful families had. And that made them easy to sweep aside. And there is one theory that no historians really accept, that they were still secretly infidels. They're still Buddhists. Well, they were said to be Zoroastrians, and they weren't Zoroastrians. They'd originally been Buddhists. So that's probably why the theory almost certainly isn't true. But we don't really know because all of these stories, as we've discussed before, are essentially operating
他们是他自己的潜在竞争王朝。或者另一种理论是，他们实际上不够强大，因为他们是外来者，因为他们来自呼罗珊，他们在伊拉克没有像更强大的家族那样有根基。这使得他们很容易被扫地出门。还有一个没有历史学家真正接受的理论，即他们仍然是秘密的异教徒。他们仍然是佛教徒。好吧，他们被说是琐罗亚斯德教徒，但他们不是。他们最初是佛教徒。所以这可能就是为什么这个理论几乎肯定不是真的。但我们并不真正知道，因为正如我们之前讨论的那样，所有这些故事本质上都是在
on the margins of the fantastical. You have archetypes, as you've been saying, of the overmighty queen mother, of the beloved queen, of the vizier, of the best friend who becomes a figure of tragedy. And of course, Harun himself, amid all this, is cast as the flower of caliphs. And so it becomes hard to get at a sense of the historical Harun. But I think the sources are good enough that you get a sense of a very, very able, very austere, very pious figure. So actually, not really like the Harun that you described in the opening passage with the sherbet and all that kind of stuff. Because actually, he'd made his name as a military man. He was a very, very keen soldier. So one of the ways that he dealt with his unpopularity with al-Hadi when he was a young man was he had gone off and fought with the Byzantines. And he actually,
幻想的边缘运作。正如你所说，你有权势过大的皇太后、受宠的王后、维齐尔、成为悲剧人物的挚友的原型。当然，哈伦本人在这一切之中，被塑造为哈里发之花。因此，很难把握历史上的哈伦。但我认为资料来源足够好，让你能感觉到一个非常、非常能干、非常严厉、非常虔诚的人物。所以实际上，并不像你在开场白中描述的那样，带着果子露之类的东西。因为实际上，他作为一名军人成名。他是一位非常、非常热衷的士兵。所以他年轻时处理与哈迪不和的方式之一就是去和拜占庭人作战。他实际上，
he'd gone so far that it was said he had rested his spear against the walls of Constantinople. And over the course of his life, he's very, very keen on doing that. So he's leading campaigns against the Byzantines almost every year. In fact, he's so committed to it that he ends up abandoning Baghdad altogether, amazingly. For someone who's so associated with the city, he ends up setting up a new capital in Raqqa. Raqqa is where the Islamic state made their own capital. But back in the time of Harun, it was very much a Christian city, but he makes it more convenient for launching campaigns against Byzantium. Right. So he's a hardened military figure.
他走得那么远，以至于据说他把长矛靠在了君士坦丁堡的城墙上。在他的一生中，他非常、非常热衷于这样做。所以他几乎每年都领导针对拜占庭人的战役。事实上，他对此非常投入，以至于他最终完全放弃了巴格达，令人惊讶。对于一个与这座城市联系如此紧密的人来说，他最终在拉卡建立了一个新首都。拉卡是伊斯兰国建立自己首都的地方。但在哈伦时代，它在很大程度上是一座基督教城市，但他让它变得更方便发动针对拜占庭的战役。没错。所以他是一个强硬的军事人物。
He's a very able diplomat. He's famous in Frankish history for having sent Charlemagne an elephant. Oh, that's a lovely story. Yes. About puzzling. I mean, getting the elephant all those hundreds of miles west. But very doable. Well, clearly.
他是一位非常有能力的外交官。他在法兰克历史上以送给查理曼大帝一头大象而闻名。哦，那是个可爱的故事。是的。关于令人困惑。我的意思是，把大象运到几百英里外。但非常可行。好吧，显然。
Well, because he sets up an excellent postal system. Well, rather he revives an excellent postal system. The Sasanians, the Persians had had a very good... So I guess I take an elephant to Aachen or whatever. The postal service under Harun were capable of doing it. But obviously he's also very hard. I mean, one thing we'd be absolutely certain about is there's no room for sentimentality in his life because he's ready to get rid of the Barmer kids. And he's a very tireless man. There's a revolt in Corozan. He goes off to suppress it.
好吧，因为他建立了一个出色的邮政系统。或者说他恢复了一个出色的邮政系统。萨珊王朝，波斯人有一个非常好的……所以我猜我把大象带到亚琛之类的。哈伦统治下的邮政服务有能力做到这一点。但显然他也非常强硬。我的意思是，我们可以绝对确定的一件事是，他的生活中没有感伤的余地，因为他准备除掉巴尔马基德家族。他是一个非常不知疲倦的人。呼罗珊发生了叛乱。他去镇压它。
He does it. And then he dies and is buried in Corozan. So definitely a very able figure. And his rule will be remembered by subsequent generations as a golden age because it is so stable, because it is so successful. But I don't think that he ranks as an absolutely game-changing ruler in the way that Augustus or Constantine or Abdul Malik are. He's famous because people look back and are nostalgic for the order that he had represented and because of his association with Baghdad at the absolute pinnacle of its greatness. And I think in the second half,
他做到了。然后他去世并被埋葬在呼罗珊。所以绝对是一个非常有能力的人物。他的统治将被后代铭记为黄金时代，因为它非常稳定，因为它非常成功。但我不认为他像奥古斯都、君士坦丁或阿卜杜勒·马利克那样，是一位绝对改变游戏规则的统治者。他出名是因为人们回顾过去，怀念他所代表的秩序，以及他与处于伟大巅峰的巴格达的联系。我认为在下半部分，
we should look at what Baghdad was actually like to the extent that we can tell under Harun al-Rashid. Okay, brilliant. So join us after the break for a deep dive into the world of Baghdad. it. What kind of espresso drinks does Julia like anyway? Is it too late to change your latte order? But with an espresso machine by KitchenAid, you wouldn't be thinking any of this, because you could have just made your espresso at home. Shop now at KitchenAid.ca. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
我们应该看看在哈伦·拉希德统治下，巴格达到底是什么样子。好的，太棒了。休息后加入我们，深入了解巴格达的世界。它。朱莉娅到底喜欢喝什么样的浓缩咖啡？现在改点拿铁还来得及吗？但如果有一台 KitchenAid 浓缩咖啡机，你就不会有这些烦恼了，因为你完全可以在家自制浓缩咖啡。立即前往 KitchenAid.ca 选购。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的余味》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的地方，在我们的问答环节，我们会揭开娱乐界的幕布，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场演出门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。
That's therestisentertainment.com. welcome back to the rest is history we are about to plunge into the seething markets and souks of baghdad the hammams the hammer the steam rooms it's all to come so come on tom provide us with some steam please well you were skeptical about the the portrayal of the family life of Harun al-Rashid and asked how mythic it is. And the same problem, of course, hangs over Baghdad because, as we've been saying, it's so mythologized. But we do have sources for it. Basically, there are three main sources, all of which come from around by the Christian reckoning, 900. So we have al-Yakubi, who I think we've mentioned before, who's a geographer and historian. He describes all the various quarters. He's kind of the Lonely Planet Guide or something like that. Gives you a sense of what it would be like actually
那是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余味》，我们即将潜入巴格达沸腾的市场和集市，哈曼，蒸汽浴室，一切即将到来，所以来吧，汤姆，请给我们提供一些蒸汽。好吧，你对哈伦·拉希德家庭生活的描述持怀疑态度，并问它有多神话。同样的问题，当然，也困扰着巴格达，因为正如我们所说，它被高度神话化了。但我们确实有关于它的资料。基本上，有三个主要来源，都来自基督教历法 900 年左右。所以我们有阿尔·雅库比，我想我们之前提到过，他是一位地理学家和历史学家。他描述了所有不同的区域。他有点像《孤独星球》指南之类的。让你感觉到实际上
to visit it. Then there is a guy called Ibn Sarrapion, whose great thing is canals. He loves the canals. We will come to the canals. Baghdad in a way is kind of the Venice of Iraq. I mean, it's kind of, we'll come to that in a minute. And then our third source is a historian called Al-Tabari who describes the tragic events that follow Harun al-Rashid's death. Because again, there is a spectacular succession crisis involving two brothers, both of whom who hate each other. So we mentioned that Harun and Zubaydah had a son, Al-Amin, and in due course, he does indeed become caliph. But Al-Amin inevitably has a younger brother who also has aspirations to become caliph. And this is a guy called Al-Mamun, who is the son
去参观它会是什么样子。然后有一个叫伊本·萨拉皮翁的人，他的伟大之处在于运河。他热爱运河。我们将谈到运河。巴格达在某种程度上是伊拉克的威尼斯。我的意思是，我们一会儿会谈到这一点。然后我们的第三个来源是一位名叫阿尔·塔巴里的历史学家，他描述了哈伦·拉希德去世后发生的悲剧事件。因为同样，涉及两个互相憎恨的兄弟的继承危机非常壮观。所以我们提到哈伦和祖拜达有一个儿子，阿明，他最终确实成为了哈里发。但阿明不可避免地有一个也渴望成为哈里发的弟弟。这就是一个叫马蒙的人，他是
of Harun by a Persian concubine. And Al-Mamun had been born on the very day that Harun himself became caliph. And so Harun is superstitious about this, thinks it may be a mark of favor from God, and so favors Al-Mamun as well. And Al-Mamun is given by Harun al-Rashid the governorship of Khorasan, which of course is the great incubator of rebellions. It's where the Abbasid revolution had begun. Sure enough, history repeats itself. Al-Mamun sends an army to attack Al-Amin in Baghdad. Al-Amin gets defeated in open battle, holds himself up in the round city in Baghdad. There's a year-long siege. Al-Mamun's army storms the round city. Al-Amin is killed on the 24th of September, 813. He is decapitated. His head is exposed on the principal bridge of the three bridges that cross the Tigris. And Al-Mamun is proclaimed caliph,
哈伦和一个波斯妃子所生。马蒙出生在哈伦成为哈里发的同一天。所以哈伦对此很迷信，认为这可能是上帝的恩宠，所以也偏爱马蒙。哈伦·拉希德给了马蒙呼罗珊的总督职位，这当然是叛乱的温床。它正是阿拔斯革命开始的地方。果然，历史重演了。马蒙派了一支军队去攻击巴格达的阿明。阿明在公开战斗中被击败，躲在巴格达的圆城里。发生了一场为期一年的围攻。马蒙的军队攻占了圆城。阿明于 813 年 9 月 24 日被杀。他被斩首。他的头颅被悬挂在横跨底格里斯河的三座桥梁的主桥上。马蒙被宣布为哈里发，
even though he doesn't actually come and live in Baghdad until 10 years after the death of al-Amin. And Tabari's account of this gives very detailed descriptions of various quarters of Baghdad and kind of the topographical points where key moments in this tragic story happen. So they're close enough, I think, to the time of Harun al-Rashid to give us some sense of what the city was like under Harun al-Rashid's rule. And at this point, we think it's probably the largest city in the world. Is that right? Yes. So you'll remember that Al-Mansur's ambition was to make it the crossroads of the universe. And this is pretty much what it's become. And there are various suggestions as to how large it was. So Andre Klot, who wrote a wonderful book about Harun al-Rashid, he suggests that it was perhaps a million, which was the size of Rome in its imperial heyday.
尽管他在阿明死后 10 年才真正来到巴格达居住。塔巴里的叙述对巴格达的各个区域以及这个悲剧故事中关键时刻发生的地理位置点给出了非常详细的描述。所以我想，它们离哈伦·拉希德的时代足够近，可以让我们了解哈伦·拉希德统治下的城市是什么样子。在这一点上，我们认为它可能是世界上最大的城市。对吗？是的。所以你会记得曼苏尔的雄心是让它成为宇宙的十字路口。这基本上就是它所变成的样子。关于它有多大，有各种各样的建议。所以安德烈·克洛特，他写了一本关于哈伦·拉希德的精彩书籍，他建议它可能有 100 万人口，这相当于罗马帝国鼎盛时期的规模。
Other accounts I've read suggest maybe 700, 600, 500,000, but certainly very, very large. And it is indisputably the most global city the world has ever seen. It has the broadest reaching trade routes of any metropolis until this moment because it has silks and porcelain from China, but it also has slaves from the frozen shores of the distant north. We talked about the slave trade to Baghdad in our episode on the Vikings, but it also has slaves from the southernmost reaches of Africa. So essentially, there is no corner of Eurasia that Baghdad is not feeding on. And as a result of this, there are massive, massive fortunes to be made because there's endless land speculation, constant process of gentrification in previously run down areas, massive housing
我读过的其他叙述建议可能是 70 万、60 万、50 万，但肯定非常、非常大。它无疑是世界上有史以来最全球化的城市。它拥有直到这一刻任何大都市中最广泛的贸易路线，因为它有来自中国的丝绸和瓷器，但它也有来自遥远北方冰冻海岸的奴隶。我们在关于维京人的那一集中谈到了巴格达的奴隶贸易，但它也有来自非洲最南端的奴隶。所以基本上，欧亚大陆没有哪个角落不是巴格达在汲取的。结果，可以赚取巨大的财富，因为有无尽的土地投机，以前破败地区的持续绅士化过程，大规模的住房
developments. And that means that people who had grants of land right at the beginning, notably the troops from Khorasan who had provided Al-Mansur with his backing, they make absolute fortunes because they're sitting in the center of the most valuable real estate on the face of the planet. So this is good for the Abbasids because it provides them with a solid, loyal bedrock of support. But it's not just land that is a source of wealth. There is also, of course, trade. Merchants are very, very admired in Islam. The Prophet himself, of course, had been a merchant. It's possible to sail down the Tigris and the Euphrates to get to Basra at the mouth of the Persian Gulf. And this is where Sinbad, of course, sets sail down the Persian Gulf and out into the Indian Ocean.
开发。这意味着那些在最初就获得土地赠予的人，特别是为曼苏尔提供支持的呼罗珊军队，他们赚取了巨大的财富，因为他们坐在地球上最有价值的房地产中心。所以这对阿拔斯王朝来说是好事，因为它为他们提供了一个坚实、忠诚的支持基础。但财富的来源不仅仅是土地。当然，还有贸易。商人在伊斯兰教中非常、非常受推崇。先知本人当然就是一位商人。可以沿着底格里斯河和幼发拉底河航行到达波斯湾口的巴士拉。当然，辛巴达就是从这里出发，沿着波斯湾驶向印度洋的。
And certainly ships are going right the way to Vietnam and to Indonesia and so on and bringing all kinds of riches back to Basra. But the real source of Baghdad's wealth is the fact that the caliphate constitutes an enormous single market, spreading from the Atlantic right the way up to the gateways of China. It's a single market in which there is a lingua franca in the form of Arabic, and Islam provides frameworks of law that enable merchants in Fez or in Khorasan to know that there will be a single standard. And so this provides enormous scope for Baghdad to basically globalize. And as in all great imperial cosmopolises, whether it be ancient Rome or contemporary New York, a consequence of this is an obsession with exotic cooking. So Baghdad is in pole position to get all those spices from India and from further afield into the Indian Ocean and beyond. But it can also get crops from across the caliphate. And of course, the soil in Mesopotamia is incredibly fertile, so they can be planted.
当然，船只一直航行到越南、印度尼西亚等地，并将各种财富带回巴士拉。但巴格达财富的真正来源在于，哈里发国构成了一个巨大的单一市场，从大西洋一直延伸到中国门户。这是一个拥有阿拉伯语作为通用语的单一市场，伊斯兰教提供了法律框架，使非斯或呼罗珊的商人能够确信存在统一的标准。因此，这为巴格达实现全球化提供了巨大的空间。正如所有伟大的帝国大都市一样，无论是古罗马还是当代纽约，其结果都是对异国烹饪的痴迷。因此，巴格达处于获取印度及印度洋更远地区所有香料的绝佳位置。它还可以从整个哈里发国获取农作物。当然，美索不达米亚的土壤极其肥沃，所以它们可以被种植。
And the caliphate plays an absolutely key role in spreading new crops. This is the period when Spain, for instance, gets orange trees brought by agronomists in the caliphate but the um the key crop in mesopotamia is sugar cane i would imagine if i was catapulted back into sort of eighth ninth century baghdad that there'll be a lot of sweet meats cakes you know those kinds of things and this is where we get that all these honey drinks and sweetened snacks and stuff. Yes. So these sugarcane fields that are outside Baghdad, across the southern reaches of Mesopotamia, that is where all those rich cakes that the odalisks in their haris are using to plump themselves up. That's where they're coming from. And even Harun himself in the Arabian Nights is cast as a cook. So there's a kind of wonderful description of him cooking a fish. Like Rick Stein.
哈里发国在传播新作物方面发挥了关键作用。例如，这一时期西班牙引进了由哈里发国的农学家带来的橙树，但美索不达米亚的关键作物是甘蔗。我想，如果我被弹射回八、九世纪的巴格达，那里会有很多甜点、蛋糕之类的东西，这就是我们得到所有这些蜂蜜饮料和甜味零食的地方。是的。所以巴格达城外、美索不达米亚南部地区的那些甘蔗田，就是后宫里的宫女们用来丰满身材的那些美味蛋糕的来源。它们就是从那里来的。甚至在《一千零一夜》中，哈伦本人也被塑造成一名厨师。书中有一段关于他烹饪鱼的精彩描述。就像里克·斯坦（Rick Stein）一样。
Very Rick Stein, yes. Or indeed, Jack Stein. When it was well cooked on one side, he turned it over with infinite skill. And when the fish was cooked to perfection, withdrew it from the pan and laid it on broad green banana leaves. Then he went into the garden to gather lemons, which he cut and arranged on the banana leaves. Oh, that sounds delicious. So Haroon is definitely a foodie and Baghdad is definitely the place to go if you want Michelin three-star restaurants, probably the greatest concentration on the face of the planet.
非常像里克·斯坦，是的。或者确实像杰克·斯坦（Jack Stein）。当鱼的一面煎熟后，他以精湛的技巧将其翻面。当鱼烹饪得恰到好处时，他将其从锅中取出，放在宽大的绿色香蕉叶上。然后他走进花园去采摘柠檬，切好并摆放在香蕉叶上。哦，听起来真美味。所以哈伦绝对是个美食家，如果你想找米其林三星餐厅，巴格达绝对是首选之地，它可能是地球上餐厅最集中的地方。
But of course, there are also extremes of poverty as well as of wealth. And a lot of the poetry that we get from Baghdad in this time, poets tend not to be very well paid. And so there's quite a lot of complaints about the extremes of wealth and poverty. So there's one, Baghdad is a marvelous place for the rich, but for the poor, a place of misery and distress. Long will I wander, confused through its streets, lost like a in the house of an infidel. And there are large slums spreading outwards into the muddy fields that stretch around Baghdad. There are beggars everywhere. And in fact, rather like in imperial Rome, the very poor have less opportunity to get ahead than domestic slaves. Because as in Rome, slaves are usually freed.
但当然，这里既有极度的贫困，也有极度的财富。我们从那个时代的巴格达得到的许多诗歌中，诗人往往报酬不高。因此，有很多关于贫富差距的抱怨。所以有一首诗说，巴格达对富人来说是个奇妙的地方，但对穷人来说，却是一个充满苦难和痛苦的地方。我将在其街道上困惑地徘徊，像异教徒家里的迷途者一样迷失。在巴格达周围延伸的泥泞田野里，有大片的贫民窟向外蔓延。到处都是乞丐。事实上，就像在罗马帝国一样，极度贫困的人比家奴更没有出人头地的机会。因为像在罗马一样，奴隶通常会被释放。
Domestic slaves are usually freed. And it's a kind of religious obligation on Muslims. It's seen as something that is a pious duty to free slaves. And so this gives to the inhabitants of Baghdad an incredibly multicultural quality because these slaves are coming from all corners of the world. And essentially, if you are a slave who is freed in Baghdad, you have a religion, Islam, that is absolutely colorblind. All that matters is that you become a Muslim. There's huge scope for you to get ahead. And so Baghdad is incredibly, if not, I mean, well, it is multicultural because there are Christians and Jews there as well, but it's definitely very, very multi-ethnic.
家奴通常会被释放。这对穆斯林来说是一种宗教义务。释放奴隶被视为一种虔诚的职责。因此，这赋予了巴格达居民一种极其多元文化的特质，因为这些奴隶来自世界各地。本质上，如果你是在巴格达被释放的奴隶，你所信仰的伊斯兰教是完全不分肤色的。唯一重要的是你成为一名穆斯林。你有巨大的空间去出人头地。所以巴格达非常，如果不是，我的意思是，它确实是多元文化的，因为那里也有基督徒和犹太人，但它绝对是非常、非常多民族的。
Again, and this is very like Rome, you are unlikely, however, to be freed if you are a laborer out in the fields. And we mentioned the sugar cane and the slaves who are working on the sugar cane fields. I mean, they have a horrible life. And as in the Caribbean and Southern United States in the 18th and 19th centuries, these slaves are generally from Africa. So they're called the Zanj, the same word from which Zanzibar comes. So they're brought from Southern Africa and they are draining the marshes, working in the sugarcane fields. So that is a source of potential danger. There are large, large numbers of resentful slaves beyond Baghdad. Tens of thousands, Tom, presumably? Yes, I would think so. And there are, of course, there so um and there are of course there are
同样，这非常像罗马，如果你是田间的劳工，你不太可能被释放。我们提到了甘蔗和在甘蔗田工作的奴隶。我的意思是，他们的生活非常糟糕。正如18和19世纪的加勒比海和美国南部一样，这些奴隶通常来自非洲。所以他们被称为“桑吉”（Zanj），也就是桑给巴尔（Zanzibar）这个词的来源。所以他们是从南部非洲被带过来的，他们在排干沼泽，在甘蔗田里工作。所以这是一个潜在的危险源。巴格达之外有大量心怀怨恨的奴隶。汤姆，大概有几万人吧？是的，我想是这样。当然，还有……当然，还有
fires there are floods there are plagues there are sectarian riots there are mafiosi uh there were gangs so it's a dangerous place and very very dependent on the kind of security that a strong caliph like harun al-rashid can provide right so the topography of it, we talked about the round city that was built by al-Mansur, and there's a great sense of what it had come to be by the time of Harun al-Rashid in a wonderful book that was written in 1900 by, he's British, even though he has a Belgian name, Guy Lestrange, Baghdad during the Abbasid Caliphate. And he says that by the time of Harun, the round city of Mansur bears the same relation to greater Baghdad as the city of London now bears to greater London,
火灾、洪水、瘟疫、宗派骚乱、黑手党、帮派，所以这是一个危险的地方，非常依赖像哈伦·拉希德这样强大的哈里发所能提供的安全保障。对吧？所以关于它的地形，我们谈到了曼苏尔建造的圆城，在1900年由盖·勒斯特兰奇（Guy Lestrange）所著的《阿拔斯哈里发时期的巴格达》一书中，对哈伦·拉希德时期它所呈现的面貌有很好的描述。他是一位英国人，尽管名字听起来像比利时人。他说，到哈伦时代，曼苏尔的圆城与大巴格达的关系，就像现在的伦敦城与大伦敦的关系一样，
which I think is great. So it's been swallowed up effectively in suburbia. Yes, and it's been improved. So the great mosque, it's been pulled down, rebuilt by Harun al-Rashid. The Palace of the Golden Gate, which listeners will remember, stands at the heart of the round city. Harun did not like it. It was used by Al-Amin, his son, in his final stand when the armies came of his younger
我觉得这很棒。所以它实际上已经被郊区吞没了。是的，而且它得到了改善。所以大清真寺被拆除，由哈伦·拉希德重建。听众们可能还记得，金门宫矗立在圆城的中心。哈伦不喜欢它。在他年轻的弟弟的军队到来时，他的儿子阿明在最后关头使用了它。
brother. And it was, I think, so badly damaged in that siege that it was never used as a royal palace again. And the great green dome with its guy on the horseback with the spear, that collapses in 941, is struck by lightning, and then by heavy rainstorms, and it kind of disintegrates. The arcades that had originally been built as markets, they are used as barracks for the Caliph's guards.
我想它在那次围攻中受损严重，以至于再也没有被用作皇家宫殿。那个巨大的绿色圆顶，上面有骑马持矛的人像，在941年倒塌了，先是被闪电击中，然后又遭遇暴雨，它就那样解体了。最初作为市场建造的拱廊，被用作哈里发卫队的营房。
And essentially, it kind of becomes a prison zone. So you have a prison as well. It's the center of the security apparatus and it it kind of therefore ceases really to be the kind of place that a caliph will want to go so it's it has its heyday under al-mansur but by by the time of harun it's again a bit like the city it's because it's not a place that people kind of go. It's there for the police and for the soldiers and for criminals to be locked up, but it's not a place you'd go and have fun times. However, fortunately, beyond the round city, there's lots of fun to be had. Because I mentioned about these canals and how it gives to Baghdad a sense of Venice. These are being threaded off from the Tigris.
本质上，它变成了一个监狱区。所以你也有一个监狱。它是安全机构的中心，因此它实际上不再是哈里发想要去的地方。所以它在曼苏尔统治下达到了鼎盛时期，但到了哈伦时代，它又有点像那个城市，因为它不是人们会去的地方。它是为了警察、士兵和关押罪犯而存在的，但它不是你会去享受美好时光的地方。然而，幸运的是，在圆城之外，有很多乐趣可以享受。因为我提到了这些运河，以及它们如何赋予巴格达一种威尼斯的感觉。这些运河是从底格里斯河引出的。
And of course, people in Mesopotamia are brilliant at irrigation. And the caliphs are the heirs of the Persian kings who had been developing this enormous network of canals. They have to be dredged, of course. You can't allow them to become fetid because that would then breed malaria. But under a caliph like Harun, who can organize all this, there's a kind of magical Venetian quality to it. And al-Makdisi, who is a geographer writing in the late 10th century, says that the people of Baghdad come, go, and move about on water. So very like Venice. And the saying in Baghdad is that every person should have an ass in his stable and a boat on the river. And of course, who has the most boats? Obviously, the caliph. And al-Amin, before he comes to his
当然，美索不达米亚的人民非常擅长灌溉。哈里发是波斯国王的继承者，波斯国王曾开发过这个巨大的运河网络。当然，它们必须进行疏浚。你不能让它们变得恶臭，因为那会滋生疟疾。但在像哈伦这样能够组织这一切的哈里发统治下，它有一种神奇的威尼斯品质。10世纪末的地理学家阿尔·马克迪西（Al-Makdisi）说，巴格达的人们在水上往来穿梭。所以非常像威尼斯。巴格达有句谚语说，每个人都应该在马厩里有一头驴，在河里有一条船。当然，谁拥有的船最多？显然是哈里发。阿明在迎来他
disastrous end, he had six processional barges in the form of respectively an eagle, a lion, a horse, an elephant, a dolphin, and a serpent. And so again, it's like the doge going out on his great triumphal barge. Yeah. So tremendous scenes. And I see from your notes that the canals have names that give us some sense of, of the city. So the canal of the clothes merchants,
灾难性的结局之前，拥有六艘游行驳船，形状分别是鹰、狮子、马、大象、海豚和蛇。所以这又像总督乘坐他的大凯旋驳船出巡一样。是的。场面非常壮观。我从你的笔记中看到，运河的名字让我们对这座城市有了一些了解。比如服装商运河，
the canal of the cooks, the canal of dogs, Tom, was the canal of dogs, not kennels, presumably. Well, that's named after the number of strays that are loose in this particular quarter. And there's also the canal of birds, which are songbirds
厨师运河，狗运河，汤姆，是狗运河，不是狗舍，大概吧。嗯，那是根据这个特定区域里游荡的流浪狗的数量命名的。还有鸟类运河，那是笼子里的鸣禽。
in cages. Well, you know, I mean, the odalisks in the Harem need songbirds in their pretty cages, don't they? Yes. It all comes back to the Harem. So this is all very Arabian night. And I think the reason why geographers and poets alike go on about the water is, of course, that it gets very hot in Iraq. And so the water is expressive of cool and freshness, beauty. And of course, it's the caliphs who command the most glorious water features. But there is a sense that it should be made available for everyone. So the rich will donate pools or fountains for the use of the poor. And the sense that also that gardens should be
嗯，你知道，后宫里的宫女们需要漂亮的笼子里的鸣禽，不是吗？是的。一切又回到了后宫。所以这一切都非常像《一千零一夜》。我认为地理学家和诗人们之所以不断谈论水，当然是因为伊拉克非常热。所以水表达了凉爽、清新和美丽。当然，是哈里发掌握着最壮丽的水景。但人们有一种感觉，它应该让每个人都能享用。所以富人会捐赠池塘或喷泉供穷人使用。而且人们也认为花园应该
made available. This is also something that I think makes Baghdad quite a livable city, despite all the heat and the stress and the dust and the stray dogs and all that kind of stuff. And of course, you can buy anything in Baghdad. I mean, that's also the reason why people come there, this great global entrepot. So the markets are focused in the region called Kark. On the west, the western side, right? It's south. It's south of the round city. And it's bordered by the Tigris on the east side and by the Pilgrim's Way, the Sabayda's bordered by the Tigris on the East side and by the Pilgrim's Way, the, uh, Sabayda's road that leads to Mecca on the West. Yes. Its main market is enormously
向公众开放。这也是我认为让巴格达成为一个相当宜居城市的原因，尽管有所有的炎热、压力、灰尘、流浪狗等等。当然，你可以在巴格达买到任何东西。我的意思是，这也是人们来到这里的原因，这个伟大的全球贸易中心。所以市场集中在名为卡尔赫（Karkh）的地区。在西边，西侧，对吧？它在南边。它在圆城的南边。东侧以底格里斯河为界，西侧以朝圣之路，即通往麦加的萨拜达（Sabayda）路为界。是的。它的主要市场非常
large. I mean, it's kind of miles long, almost a mile wide. And anyone who's been to a kind of, you know, bazaar in Istanbul or wherever, you know, it's divided up into, it has kind of allotted avenues, courtyards, you buy silks in one place or sweetmeats in another. So you can know exactly where you've got to go. And in turn, that means that all the roads have incredibly evocative names. So I think my favorite one is the market of the thorn sellers and the brambles are used to heat the baths. So it's all kind of tremendous. And the zoning, so the unpleasant trades of which butchers would be an obvious example with all the smell of the blood and the flies, they're kind of pushed out to the borders of the zone. And this means that it's quite easy for areas that in the time of Al-Mansur had been regarded as kind of working class to gentrify.
巨大。我的意思是，它有几英里长，几乎有一英里宽。任何去过伊斯坦布尔或其他地方集市的人都知道，它被划分开来，有分配好的街道、庭院，你在一个地方买丝绸，在另一个地方买甜点。所以你可以确切地知道你要去哪里。反过来，这意味着所有的道路都有非常令人回味的名字。所以我认为我最喜欢的一个是荆棘商人的市场，荆棘被用来加热浴室。所以这一切都非常了不起。而且分区，比如屠夫这种令人不快的行业，因为血腥味和苍蝇，被推到了区域的边缘。这意味着在曼苏尔时代被视为工人阶级的区域，很容易实现绅士化。
So you get quite a lot of gentrification has happened by the time of Harun al-Rashid. You have quarters that previously had been used by blacksmiths or whatever, starting to become the homes of lawyers or judges or whatever. So this is all on the western side of the Tigris, where the city was originally founded. But you also this is all on the western side of the Tigris, where the city was originally founded. But you also have mass developments on the eastern side. Listeners may remember that Alman Sir had built Al-Mahdi when he was the crown prince, a beautiful palace on the banks of the Tigris on the eastern side of the city. And this quarter, it's called Rusafahafa by the time of harun al-rashid it's one of the most glamorous quarters in the whole city it has the most beautiful and the largest mosque in the whole
所以到哈伦·拉希德时代，已经发生了相当多的绅士化。你有一些以前被铁匠或其他什么人使用的区域，开始成为律师或法官等的住所。所以这一切都在底格里斯河的西侧，也就是城市最初建立的地方。但你也有东侧的大规模开发。听众们可能记得，曼苏尔在担任王储时，在城市东侧的底格里斯河畔建造了阿尔·马赫迪（Al-Mahdi），一座美丽的宫殿。这个区域，到哈伦·拉希德时代被称为鲁萨法（Rusafa），它是整个城市中最迷人的区域之一，它拥有整个
of baghdad the palace that had been given to al-mahdi harun uses it enlarges it um there are gardens there are fountains so the description of harun that you read i mean this is probably where he should be imagined as kind of hanging out. And there are various kind of distinctive quarters that abut this kind of great complex of palaces. So north of it is the High Gate Cemetery of Baghdad, where all kinds of famous people are buried. So Abu Hanifa Dominic, who is a very famous Muslim scholar who we'll be talking about in our final episode, he's buried there. Ibn al-Shaq, who is the author of the earliest surviving biography
巴格达最美丽、最大的清真寺。哈伦使用了赠给阿尔·马赫迪的宫殿，并对其进行了扩建。那里有花园，有喷泉。所以你读到的关于哈伦的描述，我的意思是，这可能就是他应该被想象成闲逛的地方。在这一大片宫殿群附近有各种独特的区域。所以它的北面是巴格达的高门公墓，那里埋葬着各种各样的人。比如阿布·哈尼法（Abu Hanifa），一位非常著名的穆斯林学者，我们将在最后一集中讨论他，他就埋在那里。伊本·伊斯哈格（Ibn Ishaq），他是现存最早的穆罕默德传记的作者，
of Muhammad is there. Lots of caliphs will end up buried there. So that's very swanky. And then also on the Eastern Bank, you have the Christian quarter, the Dar al-Rum, the house of the Greeks, as they call it. And just to say about the status of Jews and Christians in Baghdad, they have complete toleration. They are absolutely allowed to do what they like to celebrate their festivals and their rituals. They have to pay the jizya, which is this distinctive tax. But otherwise, they're very much kind of woven into the urban fabric. Could you advance as a Christian or Jew baghdadi society if you paid the tax could you just yes absolutely keep going you could become a rich merchant you could become a commander of soldiers there's no
也在那里。许多哈里发最终也会埋在那里。所以那里非常时髦。然后在东岸，你还有基督徒区，达尔·鲁姆（Dar al-Rum），也就是他们所说的“希腊人之家”。关于巴格达犹太人和基督徒的地位，他们享有完全的宽容。他们完全被允许做他们想做的事，庆祝他们的节日和仪式。他们必须缴纳吉兹亚（jizya），这是一种特殊的税。但除此之外，他们非常融入城市结构。作为基督徒或犹太人，如果你缴纳了税款，你能在巴格达社会中晋升吗？你可以吗？是的，绝对可以。你可以继续前进，你可以成为富商，你可以成为军队指挥官，没有
prohibition against that yeah you absolutely could christians were particularly famous as doctors jewish merchants christian merchants you could do very well. And of course, they are as grateful to the security provided by Harun al-Rashid as any Muslim. So there are sectarian tensions within Baghdad, but they tend to be between different factions of Muslims rather than Muslims kicking over Christians or Jews or vice versa. So yeah, that is not a source of sectarian tension. So I think you definitely get a sense that the great theme in the Arabian Nights, which again, we'll be coming to, of a place of fabulous wealth and sophistication and a place of teeming multitudes where terrible things can happen, but also great wonders can be found, that this is rooted in a certain
禁止这样做。是的，你绝对可以。基督徒特别以医生闻名，犹太商人、基督徒商人，你可以做得很好。当然，他们和任何穆斯林一样，对哈伦·拉希德提供的安全保障心存感激。所以巴格达内部确实存在宗派紧张关系，但它们往往是穆斯林不同派系之间的，而不是穆斯林排挤基督徒或犹太人，反之亦然。所以是的，那不是宗派紧张的来源。所以我认为你绝对能感觉到《一千零一夜》中的伟大主题，我们稍后会谈到，即一个拥有惊人财富和复杂性的地方，一个熙熙攘攘、可能发生可怕事情，但也能发现伟大奇迹的地方，这植根于某种
historical reality. It is a place of slums, of violence, of robbery, of theft, but it is also a place where you have palaces stretching along the banks of the Tigris. Jafar, for instance, the beloved friend of Harunun whom he ends up killing, he develops what in London terms perhaps would be Hampton Court, great palaces along the river that are outside the main centre of conurbation. These become, again, an entire string of pleasure resorts, fountains, all the works that ultimately get swallowed up by the city. It's got a polo pitch, I read here, Tom. Yeah, it's got a polo pitch. It's got a race course. It has a park for wild beasts,
历史现实。它是一个充满贫民窟、暴力、抢劫和盗窃的地方，但它也是一个宫殿沿着底格里斯河岸延伸的地方。例如，哈伦深爱的朋友贾法尔（Jafar），最终被哈伦杀害，他开发了在伦敦看来可能是汉普顿宫那样的地方，即河边的大型宫殿，它们位于城市主要中心之外。这些地方又变成了一连串的休闲度假胜地、喷泉，所有最终被城市吞没的设施。我在这里读到，它有一个马球场，汤姆。是的，它有一个马球场。它有一个赛马场。它有一个野生动物园，
which is a tradition that goes all the way back to the ancient Persian kings, the Babylonian kings, the Assyrian kings. So the sense of Baghdad as the successor to those great ancient capitals is absolutely present there, I think. And that is why I think it's remembered. We kind of have a sense of Babylon as a great city. And I think Baghdad is absolutely the heir to that sense. And so, Tom, the obvious question is, if it's so fantastic, so brilliant, I mean, Rome, its splendor lasted for centuries. Why doesn't Baghdad's golden age last longer?
这是一种一直追溯到古代波斯国王、巴比伦国王、亚述国王的传统。所以我认为巴格达作为那些伟大古代首都继承者的感觉绝对存在于那里。这就是为什么我认为它被人们铭记。我们对巴比伦作为一个伟大城市有一种感觉。我认为巴格达绝对是那种感觉的继承者。所以，汤姆，显而易见的问题是，如果它如此美妙、如此辉煌，我的意思是，罗马，它的辉煌持续了几个世纪。为什么巴格达的黄金时代没有持续更久？
Or does it last longer? And I just don't know about it. My sense is that there's all kinds of revolts and there's a lot of stuff with slave soldiers that goes wrong. Yes. So it does remain the great global capital for several centuries. And that's why its destruction by the Mongols in the 13th century does come as the most incredible shock. But by the time the Mongols come,
还是说它持续得更久？只是我不知道而已。我的感觉是，这里发生了各种各样的叛乱，而且有很多关于奴隶士兵的事情出了问题。是的。所以它确实在几个世纪里一直保持着伟大的全球首都地位。这就是为什么它在13世纪被蒙古人摧毁时，会带来如此令人难以置信的震惊。但在蒙古人到来时，
the Golden Age is long, long vanished. The caliph has basically become a cipher, and the city itself is a much more turbulent and violent place than it had been under Harun. And that's in part because the challenge of securing a stable succession is never really solved. So we talked about how the siege of Baghdad in 813 that ends up with the death of al-Amin. There are historians who compare it to Paris in the Commune, the horrors of that, the sectarian violence that breaks out, the sufferings. As we've said, the destruction that's visited on the round city is never really repaired. Al-Mamun actually proves to be a very strong and effective caliph, but he is succeeded by his brother, a guy called Al-Mutasim. And his reign, there are kind of endless conspiracies,
黄金时代早已消失。哈里发基本上已经成为了一个傀儡，而城市本身也比哈伦统治下更加动荡和暴力。这部分是因为确保稳定继承的问题从未真正解决。所以我们谈到了813年以阿明之死告终的巴格达围城战。有历史学家将其与巴黎公社相提并论，那里的恐怖、爆发的宗派暴力、苦难。正如我们所说，圆城遭受的破坏从未真正修复。阿尔·马蒙（Al-Mamun）实际上证明是一位非常强大和有效的哈里发，但他之后由他的兄弟，一个叫阿尔·穆塔西姆（Al-Mutasim）的人继位。在他的统治期间，有各种各样的阴谋，
endless revolts. And he gets so alarmed by how unstable Baghdad is, how kind of beyond the ability of a caliph to impose law and order on it, that he actually, he says, I've had enough of this. I'm moving out of Baghdad. I'm going to found a new city, which he does it at a place called Samarra, which is famous above all for its great minaret, which is like a kind of helter skelter. I'm sure people have seen it. And of course he now, you know, he's, he's left behind that bedrock of support that the Khorasan troops had provided him. So now he needs new troops. And so he starts recruiting Turks and effectively he ends up the prisoner of, of his own. So these are the slave soldiers that you mentioned.
无休止的叛乱。他对巴格达的不稳定感到非常惊恐，对哈里发无法在其中实施法律和秩序感到无能为力，以至于他实际上说，我受够了。我要搬出巴格达。我要建立一座新城市，他在一个叫萨迈拉（Samarra）的地方做到了，那里最著名的是它的大宣礼塔，就像一种螺旋滑梯。我相信人们见过它。当然，现在，你知道，他抛弃了呼罗珊军队为他提供的支持基石。所以现在他需要新的军队。于是他开始招募突厥人，实际上他最终成为了他自己军队的囚徒。所以这些就是你提到的奴隶士兵。
And then you have escalating crises. By 865, you've got two caliphs, one in Samarra, one in Baghdad. You have rebellions from Karajites and Shias, constant theme. And then in 869, the Zanj, these black slaves who've been working out in the sugarcane fields, they launch a terrible uprising and Basra is sacked and armies rampage across Iraq for 15 years. Tens of thousands of people die. Meanwhile, chaos in the center, provinces out in the outer reaches of the caliphate start to disintegrate. And basically Baghdad never recovers the supremacy, the security, the geopolitical centrality that it had under Harun. And that, I think, is why his name is particularly commemorated by Muslim scholars, but also by the tellers of stories and
然后危机不断升级。到865年，你有两个哈里发，一个在萨迈拉，一个在巴格达。你有来自哈瓦利吉派（Karajites）和什叶派的叛乱，这是一个持续的主题。然后在869年，桑吉（Zanj），这些在甘蔗田工作的黑人奴隶，发动了一场可怕的起义，巴士拉被洗劫，军队在伊拉克横行了15年。成千上万的人死亡。与此同时，中心陷入混乱，哈里发国边远地区的省份开始瓦解。基本上，巴格达再也没有恢复它在哈伦统治下所拥有的至高无上、安全和地缘政治中心地位。我认为，这就是为什么他的名字特别受到穆斯林学者，以及随后的几个世纪里故事和
fables over the centuries that follow. And that's what we'll be coming to next time, isn't it, Tom? So we'll be looking at Baghdad's impact on the world's imagination. We'll be looking at its impact on Islam and the way it shapes this transformative religion. But also we'll be looking at the Arabian Nights and the way in which Baghdad's luster endures in the world of the Arabian Nights and the history that lies behind all that. So we'll be doing that on Thursday. If you're a member of the Restless History Club, if you're a member of what I know Tom likes to think of as our own,
寓言讲述者的纪念。这就是我们下次要谈的内容，不是吗，汤姆？所以我们将探讨巴格达对世界想象力的影响。我们将探讨它对伊斯兰教的影响以及它塑造这种变革性宗教的方式。但我们也将探讨《一千零一夜》，以及巴格达的光辉在《一千零一夜》的世界中如何持久存在，以及这一切背后的历史。所以我们将在周四做这件事。如果你是“其余的历史俱乐部”（The Restless History Club）的成员，如果你是汤姆喜欢称之为我们自己的成员，
if you're one of our Odalisks, then you will be able to listen to that right now. And if you're not, if you're living outside the round city, as it were, then you'll have to wait until Thursday. And Tom will be back with the Arabian Nights, which will be very, very exciting. We'll see you then. Goodbye.
如果你是我们的一位宫女，那么你现在就可以收听了。如果你不是，如果你住在圆城之外，那么你将不得不等到周四。汤姆将带着《一千零一夜》回来，那将是非常、非常令人兴奋的。我们到时见。再见。
See you then. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman, and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
到时见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持《其余皆娱乐》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节中，我们会揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场演出门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。
That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。